Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui dans ScienceClic,
les mathématiques de la relativité générale,
partie 8, résumé et applications.
Pour conclure cette série de vidéos, nous
allons résumer tous les concepts développés
en proposant un catalogue des différentes
solutions possibles, et en les mettant en
application dans plusieurs exemples concrets.
On pourra calculer la dilatation du temps
que subit un astronaute dans la station spatiale,
déterminer les équations qui régissent
le mouvement d’un objet tombant sur le Soleil,
et même la trajectoire de la lumière autour
d’un trou noir.
Pour commencer, résumons ensemble les différentes
étapes qui permettent de résoudre un problème,
en relativité générale.
La première étape est de déterminer la
géométrie d’espace-temps dans laquelle
on veut résoudre notre problème.
Ceci correspond à trouver la métrique que
l’on va utiliser.
Dans un univers vide, on utilisera la métrique
de Minkowski, qui décrit l’espace-temps
plat de la relativité restreinte.
Autour d’une masse sphérique, et statique,
on utilisera la métrique de Schwarzschild.
C’est la métrique la plus utilisée en
relativité générale, car elle est simple,
mais peut tout de même s’appliquer à un
grand nombre de situations.
Autour d’une planète, d’une étoile,
ou même autour d’un trou noir statique.
Il existe également un panel d’autres métriques,
plus exotiques, comme la métrique FLRW, qui
décrit l’univers tout entier à grande
échelle, la métrique de Morris-Thorne qui
décrit un trou de ver non attractif, ou encore
la métrique de Kerr, qui décrit un trou
noir tournant rapidement sur lui-même.
La seconde étape, est de choisir les coordonnées
que l’on va utiliser pour décrire notre
problème.
En fonction de notre situation, certaines
coordonnées sont plus appropriées que d’autres.
En particulier, la métrique de Minkowski
s’exprime la plupart du temps avec des coordonnées
cartésiennes qui reflètent bien son invariance
dans l’espace et dans le temps.
Et la métrique de Schwarzschild, avec des
coordonnées à symétrie sphériques, tout
comme l’astre que l’on étudie.
Cela dit, notre problème peut ne correspondre
à aucune de ces solutions habituelles, et
il va falloir dans ce cas déterminer par
nous-même les coordonnées les plus appropriées,
et partir directement de l’équation d’Einstein,
pour intégrer les différents tenseurs de
courbure, et remonter jusqu’à l’expression
du tenseur métrique.
Ce procédé peut s’avérer extrêmement
complexe, et nécessite la plupart du temps
des approximations, et des simulations informatiques.
Une fois nos coordonnées choisies, la troisième
étape consiste à analyser les symétries
de notre problème, pour réduire son nombre
de dimensions.
Par exemple, pour décrire le mouvement d’une
pomme tombant verticalement, on n’aura besoin
que d’une seule dimension d’espace, on
peut décrire sa position le long d’un seul
axe.
De même, pour un objet en orbite autour d’une
masse sphérique, la symétrie nous indique
que sa trajectoire est confinée dans un plan.
Par symétrie, l’objet n’a aucune raison
de sortir de ce plan d’un côté plutôt
que de l’autre.
Dans ce cas, on peut se ramener à deux dimensions
d’espace, en alignant nos coordonnées avec
ce plan.
Enfin, une fois notre métrique et nos coordonnées
déterminées, on va pouvoir exprimer la solution
de notre problème.
Deux possibilités s’offrent alors à nous.
Dans un premier temps, on peut vouloir exprimer
les composantes de la vitesse de notre objet,
dans l’espace-temps.
Par exemple, on peut vouloir exprimer sa vitesse
temporelle, c’est à dire le rythme auquel
s’écoule notre temps par rapport à son
temps propre.
Dans ce cas, on utilisera le fait que tous
les objets de l’univers se déplacent à
la vitesse de la lumière.
La norme de sa vitesse doit donc être égale
à la vitesse de la lumière, ce qui nous
donne une équation qui relient entre elles
les composantes de la vitesse.
Dans un second temps, une fois que l’on
connaît les différentes composantes de la
vitesse de notre objet, on peut s’intéresser
à leur accélération, c’est à dire la
façon dont elles évoluent au cours du temps
propre.
On pourra ainsi décrire des trajectoires
complètes à travers l’espace-temps.
Par exemple, on peut vouloir calculer le mouvement
d’une pomme qui tombe sur Terre, ou la trajectoire
de la Terre autour du Soleil.
Dans ce cas, il est nécessaire de calculer
les symboles de Christoffel, pour pouvoir
les injecter dans l’équation des géodésiques.
Dans le cas de la pomme par exemple, cette
équation nous dit que sa coordonnée d’altitude
va subir une accélération négative, elle
tombe.
Pour résumer, on commence par choisir une
géométrie d’espace-temps pour décrire
notre univers.
Puis on réduit le nombre de dimensions à
étudier à partir des symétries de notre
problème.
Et enfin, on utilise dans un premier temps
la norme de la vitesse, pour relier ses différentes
composantes, et dans un second temps l’équation
des géodésiques pour calculer la trajectoire
complète de l’objet.
Grâce à cette méthode nous allons pouvoir
résoudre étape par étape un grand nombre
de problèmes physiques.
Exemple 1, la dilatation du temps
Dans ce premier exemple, on souhaite déterminer
la dilatation du temps que subit un astronaute
dans la station spatiale.
Pour résoudre ce problème, nous allons suivre
les différentes étapes que l’on a énoncées
précédemment.
Tout d’abord, on choisit la métrique qui
décrit le mieux notre situation.
On considérera que la Terre est une sphère
parfaite, et on négligera sa rotation sur
elle-même qui est très faible devant la
vitesse de la lumière.
Dans ce cadre simplifié, l’espace-temps
à l’extérieur de la planète est décrit
par la métrique de Schwarzschild.
Sous sa forme la plus intuitive, la métrique
de Schwarzschild s’exprime avec des coordonnées
sphériques, mesurées depuis l’infini.
On imagine qu’on se place à très grande
distance de la planète, et qu’on mesure
le temps t, sur notre horloge, l’altitude
r de la station depuis le centre de la Terre,
et les angles theta, et phi.
Le tenseur métrique prend alors la forme
suivante.
Une fois le tenseur métrique exprimé dans
les quatre dimensions de l’espace-temps,
on va tenter de le réduire, en exploitant
les symétries du problème.
En particulier, on suppose que la station
décrit un cercle autour de la Terre.
En s’alignant sur ce cercle, on peut s’affranchir
d’une part de la coordonnée theta, car
la station orbite dans un plan, et d’autre
part de l’altitude, r, qui reste constante
tout au long de la trajectoire.
Ainsi, on peut supprimer les lignes et colonnes
qui correspondent à ces deux coordonnées.
La position de l’astronaute, dans l’espace-temps,
peut être décrite avec seulement deux dimensions
: le temps t, et l’angle phi.
Enfin, une fois le tenseur métrique exprimé
dans un système de coordonnées, on va pouvoir
passer à la résolution du problème.
La dilatation du temps que l’on veut calculer,
correspond au rapport entre le rythme du temps
de notre horloge, t, et le temps propre de
l’astronaute.
Il s’agit simplement de sa vitesse temporelle,
c’est le rythme auquel augmente la coordonnée
t au cours du temps propre.
Pour calculer cette vitesse temporelle, on
va utiliser la norme du vecteur vitesse.
Dans l’espace-temps, tous les objets se
déplacent à la vitesse de la lumière.
Notre astronaute se déplace à la fois dans
le temps, et dans l’espace, mais sa vitesse
globale dans l’espace-temps est toujours
égale à c.
La norme d’un vecteur en relativité générale,
se développe à partir du tenseur métrique,
c’est l’équivalent du théorème de Pythagore.
En développant la somme, et en y injectant
les termes de la métrique de Schwarzschild,
on obtient une équation qui relie directement
les deux composantes de la vitesse.
D’une part, la vitesse angulaire de l’astronaute,
c’est à dire le rythme auquel augmente
l’angle qu’il forme autour de la Terre,
et d’autre part sa vitesse temporelle, qui
est la valeur de dilatation nous intéresse.
En réarrangeant les termes, et en utilisant
le fait que la vitesse d’orbite de la station
est égale à sa vitesse angulaire multipliée
par son altitude, on obtient finalement l’expression
de la dilatation du temps que subit l’astronaute
par rapport à un observateur lointain.
Pour la station spatiale internationale, on
calcule une dilatation d’une nanoseconde
pour chaque seconde de temps propre, le temps
de l’astronaute s’écoule légèrement
moins vite que celui de l’observateur.
Exemple 2, une chute verticale
Dans ce deuxième exemple, on souhaite décrire
la chute d’un satellite vers le Soleil.
On considère une chute verticale, et on fait
l’approximation que le Soleil est une sphère,
statique, et peut donc être décrit par la
métrique de Schwarzschild.
On utilisera les mêmes coordonnées que dans
le cas précédent : on se place à une très
grande distance, et on mesure le temps t sur
notre horloge, l’altitude apparente r entre
le satellite et le centre du Soleil, et les
deux angles theta et phi.
Comme la chute se fait verticalement, les
angles theta et phi ne varient pas, et on
peut d'ores et déjà s'en affranchir.
La position du satellite ne dépend que de
son altitude, et du temps.
Dans cet exemple, on ne va pas s’intéresser
à la vitesse du satellite, mais à son évolution,
on cherche l’accélération de ses coordonnées.
Pour ce faire, on commence par calculer les
symboles de Christoffel.
Dans la métrique de Schwarzschild, avec nos
coordonnées, les symboles de Christoffel
prennent la forme suivante.
Une fois calculés on va pouvoir les injecter
dans l’équation des géodésiques.
L’équation des géodésiques se sépare
en deux versions, elle va nous donner l’accélération
du satellite sur chacune de ses deux coordonnées.
D’une part, son accélération temporelle,
et d’autre part l’accélération de son
altitude.
Ces deux formules nous permettent d’intégrer
la trajectoire du satellite au cours du temps
propre.
Connaissant sa vitesse à un instant donné,
on peut calculer son accélération, et ainsi
la façon dont changera cette vitesse, à
l’instant suivant.
Pour aller plus loin, il est possible d’interpréter
ces équations de façon plus élégante.
La première équation notamment peut être
mise sous une forme différente, qui nous
indique la conservation d’une certaine grandeur
tout au long de la trajectoire.
Cette grandeur est directement liée à ce
qu’on appelle l’énergie.
Dans la métrique de Schwarzschild, l’énergie
du satellite dépend de son altitude, et de
la dilatation du temps.
Exemple 3, un rayon lumineux
Pour finir, en conclusion de cette série
de vidéos, nous allons décrire ensemble
la trajectoire d'un rayon lumineux autour
d'un trou noir.
Dans le cas d'un trou noir statique, l'espace-temps
est encore une fois décrit par la métrique
de Schwarzschild.
En relativité générale, la lumière est
un cas bien particulier, que l’on va devoir
traiter différemment.
Pour comprendre, reprenons quelques notions.
On a vu dans les vidéos précédentes qu’un
objet trace une ligne d’univers dans l’espace-temps.
Cette ligne d’univers peut être graduée,
avec des intervalles de longueur fixe.
Cette graduation sur la courbe nous permet
d’interpréter la ligne d’univers comme
un déplacement, c’est ce qu’on appelle
le temps propre.
Au cours de son temps propre, l’objet se
déplace dans l’espace-temps, et on peut
définir un vecteur de vitesse spatio-temporelle.
Mais contrairement à la matière, la lumière
ne parcourt aucune distance dans l’espace-temps.
Deux points sur sa ligne d’univers sont
toujours éloignés d’une distance de 0.
On ne peut donc pas construire de temps propre
pour la lumière, car elle ne parcourt aucune
distance.
En particulier, on ne peut pas définir le
vecteur vitesse d’un rayon lumineux, car
la distance parcourue et le temps propre écoulé
sont toujours nuls.
Pour résoudre ce problème, on va donc définir
une nouvelle graduation, spécialement pour
ce rayon lumineux.
Cette nouvelle graduation, est ce qu’on
appelle un paramètre affine.
Contrairement au temps propre, le paramètre
affine n’a pas de vrai sens physique, il
ne mesure aucune distance dans l’espace-temps.
Il s’agit simplement d’une graduation,
arbitraire, qui va servir d’intermédiaire
mathématique pour les équations.
Grâce à ce paramètre affine, on peut définir
une sorte de vecteur vitesse, et ainsi utiliser
l’équation des géodésiques, qui reste
vraie.
D’autre part, on va pouvoir également utiliser
la norme de ce vecteur.
Mais à la différence d’un objet de matière,
ce pseudo vecteur vitesse que l’on a artificiellement
créé pour le rayon lumineux a une longueur
nulle, car la lumière ne parcourt aucune
distance.
Sa norme vaut donc 0.
A cette petite différence près, on peut
toujours appliquer le même raisonnement que
pour les problèmes précédents, et obtenir
les équations des géodésiques qui régissent
le trajet des rayons lumineux, au cours de
leur paramètre affine, autour d’un trou
noir.
Ces équations nous indiquent que la lumière
est déviée autour du trou noir, qui agit
comme une lentille gravitationnelle.